so we're gonna skip ahead for a minute
but I want you to consider what we've
learned so far you're a new vault hunter
and you've just joined Lilith and the
Crimson Raiders our enemies on Pandora
are a fanatical cult called the children
of the vault and from here you and
Lilith will fight side by side to
capture the recruitment center where
Lilith believes that she can recover a
key that will lead her to find vaults on
other worlds the hunt will eventually
lead us here to the holy broadcast
Center where a fearsome powerful band
Abbas named mouthpiece broadcasts
propaganda to the children of the vault
all over Pandora we're here to invade
the holy recruitment center Face
mouthpiece and liberate the key to the
vaults okay so like Randy just mentioned
we've skipped ahead in this story but if
you'll notice we've also skipped ahead
in levels so I want to take the time to
show you the skill trees in Borderlands
3 all right so when you first get your
skills in Borderlands 3 you don't just
have one action skill available to you
you have all three action skills
available to you at the moment you open
it up so then what you do is you equip
one of your action skills so we want to
take a look at the action skills so this
first one is phase grasp now phase grasp
will be reminiscent of Maya in that
she'll be able to control the
battlefield by lifting enemies up into
the air the next one here is phase cast
with phase cast she'll shoot out a
spectral form of herself to kill enemies
on the battlefield and finally we have
phase slam now phase slam is an area of
effect that comes out around Amara and
destroys enemies and knocks them back so
now as you progress once you've picked
your action skill and equipped it you'll
also open up augmentations that allow
you to further customize that action
skill so there's a way to maximize the
build of your character we've worked
hard to make sure that each of our four
characters is completely unique but even
within each character there are hundreds
of meaningful options if two people want
to team up and play the same character
they will very likely have completely
different capabilities you ready to go
let's do it
all right leveled up now one thing to
look out for is to look at the damaged
numbers that come up off the enemies
here so we'll use some of that
information later but just for now like
look at some of these numbers like 56 26
26 is there
Oh
now that's a Hyperion shotgun
Hyperion shotguns have shields that come
out let's switch back to that shotgun
[Music]
[Music]
it's a new Elemental type radiation
I hit critical mass
if irradiated enemy dies he'll explode
and radiate the enemies around them
okay that's mayhem all right I think you
clean this area up let's see what kind
of loot we can find it's an outhouse but
it's got a green light it's some good
stuff okay let's see here so Amara's
level five these weapons are level five
I want you to notice that by the way
notice the two here we've got a rare in
an epic both level five and the reason
why I want you to remember that is
because that was kind of a challenging
fight we're gonna need some help for the
next section so we're gonna bring in a
co-op buddy borderlands 3 of course is
fully cooperating network however you
like to play tomorrow just picked up the
purple turn around then let's look at
and find a co-op buddy this is Zane
Flint the operative say hi Zane alright
we're gonna switch to Zane's view can we
flip that down okay this is Zane's view
I want you to notice something here
Zane is level 25 so obviously Zane's
been playing longer than Amara who is
level 5 and if we look at Zane's lude
he's got his own instance of loot what's
going on here this is called loot
instancing it's a new optional feature
in Borderlands 3 and it allows each
cooperative player to have their own
instance of loot instance loot is
helpful for players that want to play
cooperatively but don't want to compete
for the loot that drops there's nothing
worse than when you're getting online
with randoms and there's a loot ninja in
the group right so instance loot solves
that problem for players that want to
use it the other feature that
complements this is level balancing
notice how Danes loot is not only
instanced but it's actually balanced for
his level that means the loot be enemies
everything automatically balances to the
level of the player so that everyone has
a good time and my co-op group some of
us would get ahead of the others right
and then when we come back together we
be out of whack well with instant loot
and this mode of gameplay everything
balances out now that's ok you clap see
like now there's still some of us who
actually like competing for loot or
bringing in overpowered characters to
help you know level up those lower level
characters and for those of you who are
like that we can assure you that there
is still a mode for you in Borderlands 3
it's called classic mode that's right
now that we've seen seeing the operative
let's have a look at what he can do
since Zayn is level 25 we've already
equipped a lot of action skills and our
skill points here you want to walk us to
this ball yeah let's do this
all right so the first skill we have is
digit clone now digit clone is really
cool because it not only acts as a decoy
it will actually shoot guns as well but
probably my favorite feature is the fact
that you can teleport to your digit
clone at any time and swap places this
next ability is called The Sentinel now
the signal is an autonomous drone that
will fly out to enemies and weaken those
enemies or even use your grenades if you
have grenade mods equipped and then we
have the barrier skill now Zane will
throw out a barrier in front of it it'll
block incoming bullets and things like
that but of course one of the coolest
features is that if your team or Zane or
around this barrier sometimes it'll
confer benefits like healing or even if
you fire through it it'll add elemental
types to that now probably my favorite
feature of Zane is the fact that Zane
can use to action skills at one time
that's right
and if you think about it if you think
about Zane right like he's got his
barrier which is kind of like the
soldier classes capability with that
turret he's got the Sentinel which is
almost like Mordecai's blood wing but a
little hyped up from that he's got the
digit clone which is kind of like our
assassin skill from Borderlands 2 he's
kind of like a soldier a hunter and an
assassin all wrapped up in one all right
we've got Amaro we've got Seine we know
what they can do let's let's get into
the holy broadcast center and see if we
can find mouthpiece
[Laughter]
new Let's Plays signing out for now
don't forget to like follow and obey
[Music]
these names marking targets for the
second
also check out his damage numbers right
his enemies are level 27 but his
damaging balance to Amara's can disease
in tomorrow's game right for a morrow
those enemies are level 5
[Music]
all right we clean this area let's see
if we can find some loot okay now once
again being honest you know to show the
breadth of guns that we have in the game
are just some of the bread we cheated a
little bit and added some chess with
some better weapons that red chest isn't
gonna be in the game you play we just
added that for this purpose cuz it's
okay there's plenty of red chests you
guys will be fine we'll feed you baby
baby birds that's cool we wanted to show
you some some TD organs right because
you remember TDR they're disposable
instead of reloading let me throw them
away and when you throw away a TD or gun
in Borderlands 3 you some crazy [ __ ] can
happen we've got you know guns with legs
[Music]
let's uh let's see some other options
what does this one do
we've just picked up a few TDR weapons
let's take him into the next fight
good just ignore that green on the
ground now we're just not gonna learn
are we
[Applause]
Oh
you can see that when Merv's rockets out
yeah turn another one of those Merv guys
out check this out
years all right you guys ready how you
learned we get dot
that's wicked I see some ammunition
vending machines hey walk up to that
ammo vending machine I want to show you
guys this now he's already full on ammo
but you just press that or press Y right
there and you could reload all your ammo
you don't even have to go in and buy
things one time of course you can buy
individual pieces if you want now I
don't know about you guys but whenever
you play video game and you happen upon
a room where there's ammo and vending
machines to kind of make sure you're
stocked up you'd be a pretty safe bet
that you're about to run into a boss
fight not only is Borderlands 3 a much
much larger game than any Borderlands
game before it but we've added more boss
fights than ever before because we think
boss fights are exciting opportunities
for players to have their skill tested
but also to be rewarded with kick-ass
loot so let's go ahead and see if we can
find mouthpiece all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
whose shields like an equalizer
they used his clone teleport to dodge
that area of effect that mouthpiece just
made
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man you got some loot oh yeah let's
get the loot
yeah did you guys see the gun that
mouthpiece was shooting at us with a
like kind of sound waves flying out
check this out
[Applause]
one of the greatest feelings in Bordeaux
Lanza's when an enemies using a gun
against you you kill that guy and then
you take that gun and use it against
your neck suppose I love that so much
yeah well let's do what we came here for
and let's get the ball Matt tomorrow
you're gonna pick that up
[Music]
[Laughter]
so I offered the sons matches a place in
our family but they just wanted guns and
catch they fit the family oh so you've
just met Troy aunt Irene Calypso the
Calypso twins we learned earlier that on
Pandora there's a cult call